um it's chosen the edge of the board
that's a clever one no more checks
if black's queen now steps across to
give check white will not move his king
white will block a check with his own
queen
and check the black king at the same
time a cross check a counter check
so magnus could not give check to the
white king oh wow
nice by ding the king is gonna become an
active piece and still
no way to effectively check white's pawn
protected by his queen
that's just ready it's kind of there
poised
he's basically saying i know that pawn's
going to make become a new queen soon
i don't need to rush it um yeah ding
doing everything right so finally end
game yeah and uh
well this is his kind of forte he's
fantastic at calculation
and this particular position it's all
about calculation and visualizing
where you want to hide your king or the
perfect
piece uh cooperation and uh
magnus moving his queen i mean it's it's
really difficult to kind of
find good moves for magnus i mean any
move will is okay as long as it doesn't
just immediately lose i can make a new
queen why can't
yep here comes another one you can make
a new queen i don't think black is ever
going to be able to
create some kind of checking formation
nope
the two queens cover all the critical
squares two queens are better than one
yeah white's king can just move forward
and then
journey its way over to the left side of
the board where the queens can start to
protect it yep
totally and it steps forward and
uh magnus just resigns down the queen
it's over the first game between dingley
ran and manuscripts in battle for third
place magnus won the match yesterday
but now